Alors que je la regardais faire,
pour la première fois de ma vie,
j'ai eu le sentiment inestimable
que je pouvais être utile à ce monde.
Ce sentiment était très spécial
parce que je ne suis pas faite pour être utile.
En Inde rurale, les filles sont en général considérées comme sans valeur.
Elles sont soit une responsabilité, soit un fardeau.
Elles sont seulement utiles
quand il s'agit de cuisiner, de nettoyer la maison
ou d'élever les enfants.
En étant la deuxième fille dans ma famille indienne conservatrice,
je me suis rendu compte dès mon plus jeune âge
que personne n'attendait rien de moi.
J'étais conditionnée à croire que les trois identités qui me définissaient -
pauvre fille villageoise -
signifiaient que je devais vivre une vie sans voix, ni choix.
Ces trois identités m'ont fait penser
que je n'aurais jamais dû naître.
Pourtant, je le suis.
Durant toute mon enfance, alors que je roulais des bidis avec ma mère,
je me demandais :
que me réserve l'avenir ?
Je demandais souvent à ma mère, avec beaucoup d'angoisse :
« Amma, ma vie sera-t-elle différente de la tienne ?
Est-ce que j'aurai la chance de choisir ma vie ?
D'aller à l'université ? »
Elle me répondait :
« Finis d'abord le lycée. »
Je suis sûre que ma mère n'avait aucune intention de me décourager.
Elle voulait juste que je comprenne
que mes rêves étaient peut-être trop grands pour une fille de mon village.
Quand j'avais 13 ans, j'ai trouvé une autobiographie d'Helen Keller.
Helen est devenue mon inspiration.
J'admirais son esprit indomptable.
Je voulais avoir un diplôme universitaire comme elle,
j'ai donc affronté mon père et mes proches pour qu'on m'envoie à l'université,
et ça a marché.
La dernière année du premier cycle,
je voulais désespérément échapper au mariage forcé,
j'ai donc postulé à un programme de bourse à Delhi,
à environ 2 500 km de mon village.
(Rires)
En fait, je me souviens que le seul moyen était de remplir ma demande
pendant mon trajet vers la fac.
Je n'avais pas accès aux ordinateurs,
j'ai donc dû emprunter le portable d'un camarade.
En tant que femme, je n'avais pas le droit d'être vue avec un portable,
je cachais alors son téléphone sous mon châle
et je tapais le plus lentement possible
pour ne pas être entendue.
Après plusieurs entretiens,
j'ai été acceptée dans le programme avec une bourse complète.
Mon père était perturbé, ma mère était inquiète --
(Applaudissements)
Mon père était perturbé, ma mère était inquiète,
mais j'avais des papillons dans le ventre
parce que j'allais quitter mon village
pour la première fois
pour aller étudier dans la capitale.
Parmi les 97 boursiers de cette année-là,
j'étais la seule jeune diplômée issue du milieu rural.
Personne d'autre ne me ressemblait, ni ne parlait comme moi.
Je me sentais isolée, intimidée et jugée par beaucoup.
Un camarade m'appelait « Coconut Girl ».
Qui peut deviner pourquoi ?
Personne ?
Parce que j'utilisais beaucoup d'huile de coco dans mes cheveux.
(Rires)
Un autre m'a demandé comment j'avais appris l'anglais,
et certains ne voulaient pas de moi dans leur groupe de travail
parce qu'ils pensaient que je n'étais pas capable de contribuer à la discussion.
J'ai senti que beaucoup de mes camarades pensaient qu'une personne de l'Inde rurale
ne pouvait rien apporter de valeur,
alors que la majorité de la population indienne est rurale.
Une histoire comme la mienne est considérée comme une exception,
et jamais comme une possibilité.
Je crois qu'on naît tous dans une réalité qu'on accepte aveuglément,
jusqu'à ce qu'on se réveille et qu'un nouveau monde s'ouvre.
Quand j'ai vu la première signature de ma mère sur son carnet de salaire,
quand j'ai senti l'air chaud de Delhi sur mon visage
après un trajet de 50 heures en train,
quand je me suis enfin sentie libre et moi-même,
j'ai eu un aperçu de ce nouveau monde que je désirais,
un monde dans lequel une fille comme moi n'est plus un fardeau,
mais une personne de valeur, utile
et une personne de mérite.
À la fin de ma bourse, ma vie avait changé.
J'avais non seulement retrouvé ma voix,
mais j'avais aussi le choix de me rendre utile.
J'avais 22 ans.
Je suis retournée dans mon village pour créer la fondation Bodhi Tree,
une institution qui soutient la jeunesse rurale
en leur donnant une éducation, des compétences et des opportunités.
On travaille avec les jeunes
pour changer leur vie et aider nos communautés.
Comment savoir que mon institution fonctionne ?
Il y a six mois, une nouvelle personne nous a rejoints.
Elle s'appelle Kaviarasi.
Je l'ai repérée à l'université locale de Tirunelveli
pendant l'une de mes séances de formation.
On peut voir qu'elle a un sourire remarquable.
On l'a aidée à aller étudier à l'université d'Ashoka, à Delhi.
Le meilleur, c'est qu'elle est de retour à Bodhi Tree en tant que formatrice
travaillant avec dévouement à changer la vie d'autres comme elle.
Kaviarasi ne veut pas avoir l'impression d'être une exception.
Elle veut être utile aux autres dans ce monde.
Récemment, Kaviarasi a guidé Anitha,
qui vient aussi d'un village reculé,
vit dans une maison de neuf m²,
ses parents sont aussi ouvriers agricoles.
Kaviarasi a aidé Anitha à intégrer un prestigieux programme
dans une grande fac indienne avec une bourse complète.
Devant la réticence de ses parents à l'envoyer aussi loin,
on a demandé aux membres du comité de district
de parler aux parents d'Anitha,
et ça a marché.
Et il y a Padma.
Nous sommes allées à la fac ensemble.
Elle est la première diplômée de son village.
Elle travaillait avec moi à Bodhi Tree
jusqu'à ce qu'elle décide d'aller à l'école supérieure.
Je lui ai demandé pourquoi.
Elle a dit qu'elle voulait s'assurer
ne jamais être un fardeau pour qui que ce soit
à aucun moment de sa vie.
Padma, Anitha et Kaviarasi
ont grandi dans les communautés et familles
les plus difficiles qu'on puisse imaginer.
Mais ma quête d'utilité dans ce monde
leur a servi à trouver leur utilité pour ce monde.
Bien sûr, il y a des défis.
Je sais que le changement n'arrive pas soudainement.
Je travaille beaucoup avec les familles et communautés
pour les aider à comprendre pourquoi l'éducation
est utile à tous.
Agir permet de les convaincre rapidement.
Quand ils voient leurs enfants s'instruire,
avoir un vrai travail, ils commencent à changer.
Ce qui s'est passé chez moi en est un bon exemple.
J'ai reçu une récompense pour mon travail social
du Ministre en chef de l'État.
J'allais donc passer à la télévision.
(Rires)
Tout le monde était collé à la télé, y compris mes parents.
Je voudrais croire que voir sa fille à la télé
a aussi permis à ma mère de se sentir utile.
Espérons maintenant qu'elle arrête de me forcer à me marier.
(Rires)
Trouver mon utilité m'a aidée à me libérer des identités
imposées par la société --
pauvre fille villageoise.
Trouver mon utilité m'a permis de ne pas être mise en boîte,
en cage et en bouteille.
Trouver mon utilité m'a aidée à trouver ma voix,
ma propre estime et ma liberté.
Je vous laisse avec cette réflexion : où vous sentez-vous utile à ce monde ?
Dans la réponse à cette question,
vous trouverez votre voix et votre liberté.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)